US President Donald Trump held his first
free election campaign in three months
in Tulsa Oklahoma on Saturday the indoor
event went ahead despite concerns that
it might spark a fresh coronavirus
outbreak Trump was in a defiant mood but
the much-hyped event was marred by low
turnout something Trump said was down to
media coverage of Coe bid 19 and
protesters blocking attendees from
getting access DW correspondent Stefan
Simmons was at the Trump rally in Tulsa
I spoke with him earlier and asked both
whether Trump supporters really were
blocked from getting into the venue and
I also asked how a campaign by tic-tock
users figures into this story can tell
you that no protesters were able to
block anything here I'm standing on
Denver Street right in front of the
arena where the rally happened yesterday
and nobody was blocked here Secret
Service police is that Wren and a half a
dozen other agencies they made sure that
nobody blocked entry for Trump
supporters to come to the arena so no
that's bogus nobody blocked Trump
supporters from entry now - tik-tok
apparently there was a massive amount of
tick-tock users and social media users
young Americans who managed to reserve
tickets for them or RSVP'd they RSVP'd
that they would come and had never
actually a plan to come here and that
might have triggered the campaign Trump
campaigned to say we have a 1 million
request for tickets etc they are of
course nixing this now they're shooting
back and say like no they have
sophisticated systems to filter out
bogus telephone numbers and orders
etcetera so that wasn't it they weren't
in any way cyber blocked but that leaves
of course then the question ok so why
didn't 19,000 or even more people show
up here now it's reported it was about
7,000 people who actually made it into
the arena it's gonna be an interesting
two days to sort this else we all know
that Donald Trump likes big numbers and
he didn't perform at all in terms of big
numbers yes
so what it does if nothing else has set
the stage for months to go until the
presidential election
what case I wonder can be made that the
current polls in the current situation
point to something more serious in mr.
Trump's campaign to get reelected yeah
you mentioned it the polls have Donald
Trump down and lacking behind in in a
white gap
lacking behind Democrats presidential
candidate Joe Biden that is serious for
the president and then why that is why
he was itching to get out to restart or
invigorate his campaign now with
yesterday's Tulsa event now that didn't
really work out not at all actually
everybody is talking here about empty
seats now and who is blocking protesters
well that's not the narrative the
president actually wanted to tell he
wanted to come out strong out of the
gate and show how successful he is by
bringing a lot of people together
meaning that he will have the votes in
November now that is different and
Hillary Clinton and Joe Biden is
different to people in 2016
really really really didn't like Hillary
Clinton well this is Joe Biden not to
say that he is beloved by everybody but
it is Joe Biden and not Hillary Clinton
Stephan Simmons it's going to be a very
interesting four months in from Tulsa
Oklahoma thank you very much so tell us
more I'm joined now by our reporter
Peter Rolla doll Peter a look on social
media raises the question did Trump get
trolls it looks like it you know it
turns out that a lot of these nearly 1
million people who signed up for the
event never really intended to show in
the first place instead they were really
out to stick it to Trump whom you know
we learned after inauguration really
cares about crowd sizes it appears that
a 51 year old grandmother by the name of
Mary Jo law had a little something to do
with it when she last week posted this
message on tick-tock it's two free
tickets per cell phone number because
when you register you have to give them
your cell phone number they send you a
code you put the code in
and your tickets are reserved for you so
I recommend that all of those of us that
want to see this 19 thousand seat
auditorium barely filled or completely
empty go reserve tickets now and leave
him standing there alone on the stage
what do you say right so you know tic
TOCs a platform that is better known for
dancing teenagers and political
activists this video kind of seems to
have changed out or at least brought the
two together it's being butan and times
including by these tic toc uses up
whizzing right here you all signed up
for the event and use their platform to
help spread the message and get others
to do the same the idea then spread to
Twitter where thousands followed queue
posting pictures of their tickets to the
event a couple with you know
tongue-in-cheek excuses about why they
wouldn't be able to attend after all and
you know that appears to be at least
part of the story as to why Trump's big
comeback turned out to be an even bigger
disappointment all right so we're seeing
calls to action across various social
media but can we really say that this is
the reason why attendance was so much
lower than expected know it to be fair
it does seem unlikely after all there
was no cap on the amount of tickets
available it was kind of a matter of
first-come first-served
so that's probably not the real excuse
for the arena not being completely full
but what this does tell us is that Trump
is facing a much tougher crowd than he
did in 2016 in part because there's this
new crop of you know incredibly
tech-savvy teenagers and and young
voters who understand social media so
much better than Trump does and who
really proves themselves incredibly
adept at using social media to mobilize
politically out of breath taking rate we
saw early this month when the black
lives matter protest started sweeping
the u.s. we saw fans of kpop music many
of whom have like huge followings on
social media rallying on Twitter to
drown out anti black lives matter
protest they also essentially crashed a
police app that was used to collect
pictures of protesters so Trump is
facing a tough reelection campaign on
all fronts and including on his favorite
stage which is social media all right
Peter
thank you so much for your reporting
thank you